there was a tweet yeah I think my name
changed a little bit arson yeah arson I
haven't seen a stats yet with the job me
neither he's got to be pretty good
though what was that I was on a flight
my agent texted me said stuff's going
down in San Diego right now and I'm like
what are you talking about San Diego
yeah so I guess this happened kind of at
the winter meetings but it was it was
funny that kind of blew up a little bit
and I started getting a couple text
messages from family and friends people
with the Yankees kind of what's going on
did you get excited about that like yeah
we're going to the Giants like I didn't
even get to choose yeah the one time I
get to choose